inflation is dropping and the Federal
Reserve is holding interest rates steady
signaling the potential for soft Landing
soft Landing is this the soft Landing a
soft Landing is basically economic
Nirvana they require the right mix of
policy-making skill and just plain
economic luck but we don't see soft
Landings very often because they're hard
to achieve here's
why imagine inflation as an airplane
descending to the ground when a soft
Landing occurs that essentially means
the plane or inflation manages to land
smoothly on the ground without any bumps
or turbulence which basically means the
Federal Reserve is able to bring
inflation down to its Target rate which
is about 2% without triggering a
negative reaction like a recession or
significantly raising the unemployment
rate there's a little bit of a problem
with the soft Landing analogy planes
land economies don't the economy is
always moving it's growing it's
shrinking it's not standing still so
then the question is if we have a soft
Landing do you just stay there that's
hard to do in order to soft land the
economy the FED uses its main tool to
fight inflation raising interest rates
and the Fed was until recently on a
historic run of raising interest rates
to a 22-year high after a post-pandemic
strong economic rebound pushed inflation
to more than 9% last year at today's
meeting the committee raised the target
range for the federal funds rate by a
quar percentage Point bringing the
target range to 4 and 3/4 to 5% when you
raise interest rates you know it's a
blunt instrument you don't get to
fine-tune how much you're going to slow
down the economy it isn't like lightly
tapping on the brake on the car you
stomp on it and you know things can
break the concern is that something in
the economy is going to break the most
commonly referred to example of a soft
Landing happened in the mid 1990s under
the leadership of then Fed chair Alan
Greenspan the FED raised interest rates
rapidly between 1994 and 1995 from 3% to
6% inflation and the unemployment rate
both declined the data that have been
published in the in the first weeks of
1995 have offered some indications that
the expansion May finally be slowing
from its TD and unsustainable pace of
late
1994 but today's economic challenges are
different inflation was not a problem
when the Fed was Raising interest rates
in the mid 1990s they were doing a
preemptive strike this is a completely
different scenario because the FED has
been trying to do something that's never
been done before which is soft Landing
the economy after a period of much
higher inflation soft Landings are
elusive for a reason because in order to
land the airplane you have to avoid a
lot of turbulence like Energy prices a
hot economy Fed rate hikes and financial
crises there are so many unknowns in the
economy what's going to happen to oil
prices are consumers suddenly going to
feel like they've gotten their fill of
Taylor Swift and Beyonce and they don't
need to spend money anymore and they're
not so confident about their income
situation jobs are maybe harder to get
and so they pull back one of the primary
threats to a soft Landing the FED itself
If the Fed holds rates too tight for too
long it could risk a severe
downturn inflation has cooled to 3.1%
and the unemployment rate dropped to
3.7% prompting the FED to keep interest
rates steady I have always felt since
the beginning uh that there was a
possibility because of the
unusual situation that the economy could
cool off uh in a way that enabled
inflation to come down without the kind
of large job losses that have often been
associated with high inflation and
tightening Cycles they're in weight and
CA mode they think they've probably done
enough but they don't want to declare
Victory or mission accomplished
prematurely it would be embarrassing and
it could be painful for the economy if
they said they were done and then they
had to go raise interest rates again
while the inflation rate or the airplane
appears to be descending in the right
direction it doesn't necessarily mean
the FED has soft landed the economy a
lot could change at any given time if we
don't have a soft Landing it's probably
because we have a recession and then the
question is how bad does it get is it a
mild recession the other side of that is
that we don't have any kind of downturn
and in that case the FED would probably
get nervous if inflation didn't come
down enough and the economy started to
regain speed I think the reason soft
Landings are so difficult to achieve is
they just require the right mix of luck
and skill it's hard to know without
seeing the future where exactly you
should set interest
[Music]
rates